good morning from riga latvia we are
here with global national reporting from
a country that has deep concerns about
potential russian aggression towards
baltic countries like this one one with
a history of russian invasion and
concern that it shares borders with both
russia and belarus just this morning as
we were setting up for our conversation
with you a latvian man walked past us
and asked us if we were russian media
when we said no we were canadian he
indicated that i should follow him and
this will give you an idea of how high
the emotions are running for folks here
in latvia he began to walk and as he did
so he took some bottles out of the bag
he was carrying in those bottles as
you'll see here paint and what he threw
it on the building behind us is the
russian embassy a protest using the
colors of the ukrainian flag yellow and
blue and then here as you can see red
paint which he told us represents the
blood of ukrainian children he continued
on to this post before he was stopped by
the latvian police he spoke briefly to
us and will tell you
we'll show you pardon me what he had to
say
this is a child's blood
from
there are currently 540 canadian armed
forces troops here in latvia with
another 120 on the way we're on our way
to visit them today they're here to
deter russia from invading latvia the
americans are also going to be shoring
up the contribution to latvia about 300
american airborne airborne soldiers are
on their way to latvia but certainly
here in this country a lot of concern
about their future a lot of concern
about vladimir putin's intentions and a
lot of desire to feel support from nato
mercedes stephenson riga latvia